I am so excited to be here  I like can't even contain myself I'm  super excited I am so excited  the adrenaline is finally pumping the  Victoria's Secret Fashion Show  supermodels killed it on the catwalk  Wednesday night and now ET is taking you  inside their star-studded after-party at  the Mandarin Oriental Hotel in Paris  it's been a huge dream come true of mine  my whole life after slaying in this wild  ensemble kendall Jenner hit up the post  party bash to dance  the 21 year-old sat in the DJ booth and  even put on headphones at one point to  help spin some tunes he's a great friend  Bella Hadid was also spotted inside  mingling with her ex The Weeknd who  performed during the runway show we're  all celebrating together so it's just  gonna be a fun day but they weren't the  only former flames hanging out long time  angel Adriana Lima was at the event  chillin with her ex Lenny Kravitz the  former couple was briefly engaged in  2002 I'm really excited  [Music]  you